- If I only worked out when I felt good,
I'd be a fat f--k,
'cause there's a lot of
days I don't want to do it.
If nobody ever punches you in the face,
you don't really appreciate safety.
'Cause a lot of people don't
even understand what safety is.
Some people really love their life,
just sit around and f--k off.
When I sit around and
f--k off, I don't like me.
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is Believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the
major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from commentator
and podcast host Joe Rogan,
and my take on his Top Ten
Rules for Success, Volume Two.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- The one thing that discipline
definitely does help you with
is it helps you get things done,
and when you get things done,
when you actually do things,
you have more success.
If you have more success,
and sometimes a big part of success
is just not being f---ing
lazy and just doin' it.
That's like 90% of it is just showing up.
Get there and start working.
Like, you're not going to
feel perfect every day.
If I only worked out when I felt good,
I'd be a fat f--k,
'cause there's a lot of
days I don't want to do it.
It's pretty much the same with everybody
that actually gets good at something.
There's got to be those
days you push through,
and they're probably
going to be more numerous
than the days you don't.
And so the benefit of
discipline, in my eyes,
has always been that through
discipline I get things done.
I always say that I'm like, the most lazy,
disciplined person I know
because I don't want to
do it but I always do.
Write it down.
Write down everything you want to do.
And I don't mean crazy s--t,
like, "I'm going to be
the Prince of Brunei,
I'm going to have a base on the moon."
Shut up. This is what I want you to do.
Write down what you would
like to fix about your life
and then if you're 30 pounds overweight,
you want to lose 30 pounds?
Do it the right way,
start eating vegetables
monitor your calories,
write down what you eat,
exercise every day,
force yourself to do it.
Say you're the general,
the brain is the general,
the troops are the body, the
troops don't want to listen
but you go f--k you, you listen,
and you get up and you do it.
And then you get to write it down.
If you don't write it down,
you don't eat, you don't f--k,
you don't s--t, you don't shower.
Write that s--t down so you do it.
It's like brushing your teeth,
it's not something, "I don't
want to brush my teeth today."
What do you want,
your teeth to rot out of your head,
you f-----g dunce?
Just do it, just do it,
make yourself do it.
And if you do that,
if you write s--t down and do that,
you can change who the f--k you are.
Our bodies for whatever
reason, most people,
their associations are to avoid anything
that's uncomfortable,
but it's so illogical,
because when you look at comfort
and you look at success and progress
and the eventual, the
feelings of accomplishment,
and of getting past certain hurdles
in terms of like how you feel about life,
a lot of those are
connected to discomfort.
Like, discomfort is your
friend, it really is.
Like, discomfort and not being happy
and content with certain
situations in life
or certain feelings in life,
they're massive, massive motivators,
and they're amazing at
facilitating change.
And yet our instinct is to avoid those
and just sit on the couch
and watch some f-----g reality show
about dudes who make moonshine
with our jaw open like guhhh.
It's bizarre.
'Cause a lot of artists and comics,
I bet musicians as well,
but were writers for sure.
One of the big problems is
sitting down and doing the work.
And you got to,
and Pressfield talks about that,
in the most concise and beautiful way,
and he labels it like an enemy,
he calls it resistance, you know,
and that you have to sit down,
you have to overcome resistance,
and that the pro goes to work,
and it doesn't matter if you're sick,
doesn't matter if you have kids,
doesn't matter what,
you're a pro and you go to work.
It puts it in your head
that this is what I do,
and you have pride in that.
And then when you are in
front of that keyboard
and you look down at
the count and it says,
I got a f---- a thousand words today,
I put a thousand words in.
And you're doing the work,
and out of that work, gems blossom.
Little things, but you might have a day
where you just write nothing but dogs--t.
So what? Show up again tomorrow,
and tomorrow out of that
dogs--t, a flower will emerge.
You never know and that's
the only way to develop real,
like, to really develop your
potential 100% in anything.
If I look back on anything I've ever done,
mistakes I've ever made,
paths that I, you know,
something that I put out
that I didn't quite think,
man, maybe if I just waited three months
before I released that,
or maybe I should have re-edited
that blog post a couple more
times before I put it online,
those things drive me f-----g crazy,
the b------t things that I've
done have driven me crazy,
yelling at someone I didn't
have to yell at them for,
whatever, but the most important thing
is always for all people to recognize
that you're not who you were a year ago.
You're not who you were five years ago,
you're not who you were last week.
You're who you are now,
and this is the only s--t
you have control over.
So you've got to regulate
how much you dwell
on regrets of the past,
you really got to be careful,
because it's good to have a little,
because my regrets,
whether it's things of
a professional nature,
or the very few regrets friendship-wise,
which is one thing that
makes me very happy,
but you know, there's, life is strange.
There's a lot going on,
there's a lot of factors
happening in life,
but for sure, who I am now
wouldn't have ever happened
if I didn't f--k up.
If I didn't make those mistakes
I wouldn't have understand
the importance of friendship and kindness,
and if I hadn't been cruel
at some point in my life
or someone hadn't been cruel to me,
I wouldn't understand the beauty of love.
I wouldn't understand the full range of it
'cause I hadn't felt the sting.
If nobody ever punches you in the face,
you don't really appreciate safety,
'cause a lot of people don't
even understand what safety is.
Oh we're safe, we're safe,
but you are so not safe.
At any moment, you know,
and when someone's punched you in the face
a bunch of times
and you've been in a street fight
with some guy you barely knew,
or you got in an argument with,
there's something about
regular safety that's sweeter,
it's more delicious, it's more delicious.
It's way better to drive your car straight
after you almost lost control on a turn,
like (screeching)
and then you get back
straight, you're like woah.
I'm not saying that you should
go sideways around corners,
but what I am saying is
that there's a f-----g
yin and a yang to this world, man,
and you've got to fuel
yourself with the f---ups,
and most people get
stuck in these patterns
because they define
themselves as a f----up,
or they define themselves as the person
who doesn't follow through on their ideas,
or a person who doesn't pursue
their real interest in loves,
you define yourself by that.
"Well, you know, I start
things and then I quit."
No you don't.
No, you have started things and you quit,
and it gives you a
horrible sense of regret
that's made you define yourself by that.
You don't have to do that.
Your life would feel better and richer
if you had a goal, you chased that goal,
you accomplished some things,
and you would get this
boost of confidence,
you would get this boost of self-esteem,
like whatever it is
that you're into doing.
Maybe you're into drawing comic books.
Maybe you're into making
pottery or sculptures
but find whatever the f--- that is,
and pursue that instead of doing nothing.
Like, the people that are doing nothing,
those are the real...
Look, doing something might be as simple
as, like, that Alex Honnold guy.
He just climbs rocks
but he's a world class rock climber.
- [Interviewer] That's something though.
- It's something.
- [Host] I get to where
I have to tell people
things that are true that
are even embarrassing
about me now because it's like,
it's so weird, you can feel the energy.
You guys want to talk about that?
'Cause, I mean, you brought this up.
Elaborate on how strength,
'cause few know this,
few get to talk hours a
day in front of people
and then learn that it
becomes a real relationship.
- Well yeah, it definitely does
and you know what else is?
God damn, you learn so much
from those people, man.
You know, even people who are critical.
Like they send you a link to correct you,
like, "This is the real information
and you have the inaccurate information."
Like, if you don't have an
ego about all that (beep),
if you can deal with the
fact that you might be wrong,
or there might be,
you might have jumped to a conclusion,
there might be many possible scenarios--
- [Host] It's a giant think-tank.
- Yeah, you learn so much
from people on Twitter, man.
You know, a lot of people
will complain about,
like, negative things on Twitter.
I don't get that much
negative (beep) on Twitter,
but I occasionally get like,
"Yo, Imma punch you in your
face if I see you, faggot!"
- [Host] That's little kids.
- But even in negative (beep),
you usually can grab, like,
something from some of the negative stuff.
Like, even if there's a
ton of negative (beep),
usually there's like, 1% truth to it,
where that 1% will kind of stick
in the back of your head,
where you're like, all right,
he took it to like, the next level,
but I do understand that 1%
of what he's talking about.
- Yeah, you can get a hater who's like,
90% hater, but 10% has a point--
- [Host] It helps you!
- It does help you.
I really believe it.
It's a terrible feeling,
that feeling when someone's hating on you,
but I find it very beneficial
for two reasons.
One, because it's like snake venom.
Because if you get bit by a rattlesnake,
and you've never been bit
by a rattlesnake before,
it will (beep) you up.
Like, someone who's never been famous
and then all of a sudden
decides to do a reality show
and then they get all these
insults hurled at them
from every direction online,
that has got to be horrific.
That's just got to be torturous.
But when you take a
little bit of hate venom,
and a little bit of hate venom,
then you develop an immunity to it.
You kind of understand what it is.
- [Host] It becomes enjoyable!
- Well, then it becomes
a checking mechanism,
and I look at it almost like
as if it's an algorithm.
And I look at like, well,
this negative comin' in,
like, how much does it affect me,
and how much does it affect
the positivity that I put out?
Like, and if I dwell on it,
well then it'll surely (beep) me up,
but if I just look at it
and if I truly look at myself to say,
okay, do they have a point?
And if they do have a point,
if I am bein' a (beep),
like, I got to, that's very important
to be honest about that
and to look at that.
I enjoy a lot of things,
and what I've found that the best way
to live my life for me.
I'm not sayin', you know, other people,
some people really love their life
to sit around and f--k off.
When I sit around a f--k off,
I don't like me.
I like to get things done.
But the things that I do,
they're recreational, they're all fun.
Like, Disneyland was fun
as f--k with my kids,
the Eddie Bravo Invitational
was fun as f--k,
the UFC was fun as f--k,
my show, sold-out show at the KA Theater
where they do the Cirque de Soleil at MGM
with Joey Diaz and Jim Norton,
Friday night, fun as f--k.
- [Host] The book is fun as f--k, too.
- The book, those are jobs, right?
But those are fun things.
And training is fun,
stand-up comedy couldn't be any funner.
You know, the only real work work
is like, I got to discipline myself
to sometimes work out
when I don't want to,
write when I don't want to.
But this is how I feel,
it's harder for me to not
do what I'm supposed to do
than it is for me to do
what I'm supposed to do,
'cause if I don't do
then I deal with regret and doubt.
I've done it before.
I've done it a lot of my life,
I've felt those feelings,
I don't like it.
So what I do is I just don't do that.
I just say, well, what is the difference?
If I don't do it,
then I'm going to have to
feel like I didn't do it,
and feel like a loser,
so get after it, b---h.
We were talkin' before this podcast
about Holly Holm's
victory over Ronda Rousey,
and one of the things
that we were talkin' about
was that Ronda had this very linear,
straightforward attack.
You knew she was coming,
and Holly is a master at countering,
so all she had to do was wait and move,
and Ronda was coming in one direction.
There was no variation--
- There was no creativity.
It was a mad bulldog rush that had worked
on everybody else before.
But she found one person who
was a virtuoso at movement,
and she needed creativity
and it wasn't there,
and she needed that
experience that came with
having faced someone
who knew that position
and had a deep understanding
of that movement,
and she didn't have
that in her repertoire,
and so that's the result that we saw.
Like a striker like Anderson Silva
is extremely creative.
If you watch, he's got a
fight versus Tony Fryklund
in Cage Warriors.
Cage Warriors?
What the f--k was it called, in England?
Small organization in England.
I think it's called Cage Warriors--
- [Host] It was Cage Warriors, yeah.
- Where he practiced this
step-in uppercut elbow,
like a sideways elbow,
and his coach was goin',
"You're f--kin' crazy,
stop practicing that,"
and he would make his
wife hold the pillow,
because his coach didn't want him
to practice it anymore,
'cause he thought he was wasting his time.
So he practiced, his wife
would hold a pillow for him,
and he'd step in and
throw this uppercut elbow.
That's what he knocked out Fryklund with.
And obviously Fryklund was
outclassed in that fight,
but he wanted to make a point.
And like the front kick that he landed
in the face of Vitor Belfort.
Vitor never saw that shit comin',
'cause nobody had done that to him before,
'cause nobody had done that
in the history of the UFC.
Nobody had ever knocked anybody out
with the first kick you
learn in martial arts.
But the creativity to
try something like that,
he would throw punches to
your thigh from standing,
he would throw a jab to your thigh.
He would throw a crescent kick,
an inside crescent kick to your face,
like what the f--k?
It was part of what made him
such an effective striker,
is that he threw these
things that you just
didn't expect him to do.
People who are in jiu jitsu
and train on a regular basis,
they're healthier people.
Their egos are healthier, especially men.
They're easier to talk to,
they're easier to hang out with
because they're facing
reality on a regular basis.
If somebody,
my (mumbling) teacher told
me when I was a little kid,
that I never forgot was that martial arts
are a vehicle for developing
your human potential,
and nothing in my life has ever
put me in face with reality
better than jiu jitsu,
'cause I think, you
know, in life we can all
distort our perception of things
in order to make ourselves
more comfortable,
accept where we are,
and there's a lot of people out there
that're runnin' around
in life full of s--t.
You can't be full of
s--t and do jiu jitsu.
When you do jiu jitsu it's impossible
to be full of s--t because
reality comes at you
in the purest form possible.
A life-or-death struggle
using your determination,
your focus, your techniques, your mind,
and your training, over
and over and over again.
And it's reality,
and if you f--k up and you
get caught in a triangle,
you've got to tap and that
is the end of the story.
It's as real as it can get,
and that has made me a better person.
It has made me a better man,
it's made me understand myself,
my weaknesses, my strengths,
the s--t I need to work on,
jiu jitsu has been one of
the most valuable tools
I've ever had in my life.
(kicks echoing)
(blows echoing)
(vocalizing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed.
If you want to get your pick
of who I should profile next
in the Top Tens,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Jean Fredeling.
Jean, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and posting that awesome
picture on Instagram,
I really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love,
I'll see you soon.
- It's very rare that
someone is successful
that doesn't have a crazy schedule,
and if they are, they're
not going to appreciate it.
They're going to, you know, like,
but it's, it's all like,
what is where you're at?
Like, is where you're
at where you want to be?
Like, are you enjoying it?
Because I'm, what I'm happy about the most
is that I enjoy what I do.
So when I'm doing,
like if I was workin' as a CEO
of some f--kin' corporation
or somethin' like that
and I was puttin' all these crazy hours,
like the same kind of hours I put in now,
the same kind of effort,
I'd probably be a miserable, drunk,
pill-poppin' psychopath who's just lookin'
to escape and go bang
hookers or somethin'.
I'd be lookin' for some sort of a release.